during this brutal moment in the fanatic
john travolta's fingers get shot off
this is what it looked like in a test
shoot as the fx team was figuring out
how to make it work on camera
to create fake injuries for movies and
tv shows makeup artists need an intimate
understanding of the human anatomy in
order to say create an exact replica of
travolta's hand and they need to know
what looks best on camera like using
pressurized air to blow the fingers off
that replica
here's how seven gory makeup effects are
created
for this scene in the irishman where
robert de niro stomps on and breaks a
shopkeeper's hand spf x had to go beyond
looks and make something that would also
move realistically bending and breaking
in just the right way it started with
molding the arm in skin-like silicone
mixed with plaster so the final piece
was somewhat translucent and rigid but
instead of filling it in the fx artists
added a metal armature a frame similar
to what you'd see inside a stop motion
puppet while the outer layer of the arm
provided rigidness this armature created
more bends in the hand and fingers
when filming they placed the fake arm in
actor marco greco's sleeve and carefully
positioned the camera so that his body
blocked his real arm
the result was almost too effective
according to spfx's brett schmidt during
one of the takes one of the fingers
broke and spun around
exactly the kind of disturbing movie
magic they were hoping for
in the 2019 film the fanatic john
travolta's character gets shot in the
hand and loses his fingers it's a
gruesome moment that primarily relied on
practical effects special makeup effects
artist mike marino and his team had to
construct a realistic looking prosthetic
hand with detachable fingers they create
the base like any other prosthetic piece
first they cast it in silicone for skin
like translucency with hairs punched in
for realism they created the hand and
forearm together but they needed to
attach the fingers separately they
rigged the fake hand to a series of
tubes and pressurized air allowing the
fingers to blow off on cue and blood to
spurt out of the wounds at the same time
to hide the apparatus from viewers they
used a clever camera angle that you can
see here
watching the finished scene you'd never
know the hand wasn't attached to
anything
in the hbo series i know this much is
true mark ruffalo's character cuts off
his own hand his resulting injury is
frequently visible on camera but
creating the illusion of a missing limb
requires not only digital effects but
also careful attention to practical
details according to pro wren's mike
marino a green glove would make his hand
look too long and unnatural so instead
mourinho painted ruffalo's hand a
specific shade of green this allowed
fuse fx to digitally erase his real hand
from the shots
with his hand gone ruffalo also wore a
prosthetic piece to further emphasize
the injury mourinho made two designs
depending on which one the scene
dictated a fresh bloodier wound and a
cleaner sewn up wound
in season two of westworld actress rinko
kikuchi splits the shogun's head in half
but since the shogun's body continues to
squirm around the team couldn't just
make a prosthetic head they had to
consider the entire body
justin raleigh and his team at fractured
fx also had to create this injury with
several different camera angles in mind
they first took a silicone life cast of
the actor's head to capture every
physical bit of his face they then made
a replica out of clay which allowed them
to sculpt details before casting it in
more silicone and then punching in all
the characters head and facial hair
unlike other decapitated heads on the
show this one was split through the
cheek meaning raleigh had to construct a
tongue esophagus and the surrounding
muscle and tissue inside the head but
the trickiest part was this moment when
the shogun takes a few steps before
collapsing so the fake head was actually
created so it could be worn by a stunt
performer and that blue hood he's
wearing allowed the vfx team to erase
him so his real head wouldn't pop up on
camera
burn wounds are a common injury in tv
shows and movies but making them look
realistic involves a close attention to
texture and color so special makeup
effects artist ben bornstein turns to a
surprising reference burned chicken
this is particularly helpful in picking
out the color palette for fresh burns
heavy black in the deepest part of the
wounds shades of red and lots of yellow
besides heavy prosthetics bornstein can
also create convincing burns with much
less time-consuming methods like 3d
printed wounds for background characters
or bald cap vinyl pieces that have
actually been set on fire some of these
pieces are filled with ky jelly to
create depth and are then blended onto a
painted spot on a performer's arm
in the end the most convincing form of
this injury is when all of these methods
are blended together and you can't tell
which is which
in 1990s the grifters john cusack gets
slashed in the throat with glass this
wound required a fake neck piece but
back then prosthetic pieces were mostly
made with foam latex which would have
soaked up all the fake blood used in the
scene to make this piece last through
multiple takes studio adi's tom woodruff
jr and alec gillis constructed a fake
neck out of much sturdier gelatin
woodruff and gillis then made an
incision in the appliance right here
that would be the jugular vein which
according to woodruff would make the
character realistically bleed the most
they loaded blood into a large syringe
that was connected to a flexible tube
under cusex outfit which connected to a
flat tube under the neck when he got hit
with the briefcase and the glass
shattered they pushed down on the
syringe and released the fake blood so
it looks like the glass he's holding is
what really cuts him
the operation scenes justin raleigh
worked on in westworld and the nick went
far beyond squirts of blood crafting
realistic surgery wounds involves
thinking backwards down through the
different layers of skin fat and muscle
when creating an original negative mold
raleigh works in reverse to control the
thickness of each layer
from reading anatomy textbooks raleigh
realized that tandyway newton's inner
skin layer wouldn't be bare but instead
covered in a layer of fat blending the
pieces perfectly into newton's real skin
made it look like the wound was actually
part of her body but he did have to dial
some details back by holding back on
fake blood all of those muscles and
vessels specific to human neck looked
much clearer on camera
all of the deep research endless
experimentation and knowledge of what
looks good on camera is what takes gore
makeup from good to great
so the next time you see blood squirting
out of an actor's body remember that
there was a whole crew making sure they
hit the right vein
[Music]